Spencer if you were going to make
another 50 000 movie how would you start
so I'm not sure exactly just because
it is really it's really difficult to
make a movie at any level
um I will say though
um
where I was at at that point in my life
and this can help other people we were
at a point where we were in film school
and we realized hey we're at a really
unique point in our lives where we can
borrow the film school's equipment we
have you know Free Labor from all these
film students who are super excited we
have the film uh the student film
insurance and we are we don't have
full-time jobs yet we're not repaying
our student loans yet so it was kind of
The Perfect Storm and kind of the
perfect time to make a movie
um and so I'm not going to go out and
say oh I encourage everyone in film
school to go make a feature you know
because it is so much work I would
encourage you to do it if you already
know in your heart that you need to do
it and you're already set on it then
yeah go for it you know if you if you
are kind of in your later years in film
school you're a junior senior whatever
it could be a really wise move and it's
a very unique opportunity that you might
not get at any other point in your life
so so that's what we did and it worked
it worked out really well for us
so let me see if I understand you're not
sure if you would make another one 450
000 or you're not sure what you would do
differently
um I wouldn't do anything differently
with the way we set up and did space
waves
um as far as just you know deciding to
do it at that point in our lives and
kind of the the resources we utilized I
think we made the Right Moves there
um it would take a lot more
um effort and work to be Scrappy and to
do another fifty thousand dollar movie
now now that I'm out of film school and
I don't have access to all of that
equipment and insurance and things such
as that however if I was to make another
fifty thousand dollar movie I would do
the same thing that we did earlier with
space waves which is just played play to
my strengths try to get as many favors
as possible
um you know contact the film school and
be like hey is there any discount for an
alumni to use your camera or find a DP
who already had has a good camera things
like that just find ways to cut corners
and save money every which way you can
and like I've mentioned like locations
are a big thing trying to get free
locations you know pay your actors
because they're they're important and
they're the talent and you want to honor
them but even like you know crew members
it's like see if you can get favors you
know maybe somebody's not able to be on
for the whole set maybe they could be on
for a few days here or there and just
yeah just try to think creatively and do
it that way and plus the locations it
was it was easier for you to take
everybody up there with the lodging that
you had available right then keep them
down here and get hotels yeah yeah right
and also too probably the moral support
you probably felt yeah there too and
that's where we had to shoot the movie
you know I wrote it you know about
NorCal and Grass Valley and that's where
I wanted to shoot the movie I didn't
want to shoot a movie down here in SoCal
with a lot of red tape and hard to get
locations and all that and I wanted the
movie to reflect a very small town kind
of just unique vibe
yeah how do you think you could have
saved more money
man I don't know if I knew then uh that
would have been good I'm not sure
it was hard it was hard to save money
like just every step of the way
um
I honestly don't know if we could have
saved any more money than we did yeah
not sure how was craft services and crew
feed like what you had family and
friends yeah family and friends my mom
helped under that she was craft Services
which was amazing so she'd make a bunch
of food and then drive over to set and
feed us which was amazing
um and uh
yeah but that was another thing that um
we kind of forgot about as we got to set
like wait who's making the food and how
are we eating because we were so focused
on like making the movie and so my mom
came in and like really saved the day
and helped us out on production and just
kind of got
um yeah just made herself available and
started doing craft services for us nice
yeah
can you break down the fifty thousand
dollar budget where was most of the
money spent I realized it was over a
period of years yeah so I would say
probably
probably 20K was spent on set and doing
you know just filming of the film of the
movie and then probably another 10K or a
little more was spent on all aspects of
post-production and then um the
remaining was spent on the aggregator
and an entertainment lawyer and some
other various things like that
what did the entertainment lawyer do for
you he reviewed our chain of title and
so um for those of you who don't know
what that is that is something that you
need to have if you want to be taken
seriously and if you want to have a
product that can actually make money and
have all your um go through the right
legal Hoops basically so we made an LLC
so space waves film is a business it's
an LLC and so we made our chain of title
which is basically a collection of
location agreements actor agreements
music licensing it's just a big binder
full of all the permissions and so that
way you bring that to a lawyer they
check over it they go oh you might need
to revise this contractor that one and
they basically make sure everything is
good and you're all protected legally
and so that way you have a rock solid
product where you know then you could go
sell it to a distributor or get it on
Netflix or wherever you know we did self
distribute Asian so it wasn't as
important because you know we're able to
self-distribute
um with basically no questions asked or
whatever however if we were to run into
some sort of legal trouble or something
we would need that chain of title to be
like no look we have all these location
agreements um so it's something that you
definitely need to have as a filmmaker
and I'm glad that we did it
um that I will say that was that we're a
gr there was a big regret there though
that we we kind of had to retroactively
get a lot of these talent and location
agreements and stuff signed later
because we didn't really know about that
at the time of making the film
um so we kind of yeah had to get some of
those things signed later and it was a
bit of a process and it took a while to
kind of get that all um buttoned up but
we got it done eventually
and the aggregator
um how does that work
so if you want to get onto iTunes Google
play YouTube movies or Amazon Amazon you
are currently you are able to put it on
yourself without an aggregator but the
aggregator basically they charge a fee
and you pay an upfront fee and then they
put your movie on these different
platforms and so iTunes
um they you know they only accept movies
from their approved aggregators so you
can't just upload to iTunes you have to
go through a third party to do that but
basically they tell you the aggregator
tells you hey we need art in these
aspect ratios and we need the film and
these the specs this all these different
requirements whatever and then they go
through a QC Quality Control process and
they just get the film ready to
um you know go up on all these different
platforms and they they take care of it
all
and is that in perpetuity or there's a
contract where it's it ends at a certain
point you have to renew it
um I believe
um with bitmax which is who we went with
for space waves it's like a three-year
contract and then you have to pay like a
renewal fee
um it's not too expensive but um I think
that's that's what we went with Spencer
what are the biggest lessons you learned
from the production
so one thing that I learned during the
production was to Stamp Out the Sparks
before they become forest fires because
um there was a few moments on set where
you know things would happen that
weren't necessarily good between the
crew like you know little arguments or
disagreements or something and then you
just kind of BL you know brush past it
and don't acknowledge it and then
sometimes those can get worse you know
whether that's
um just some irritability within the
crew or confusion or whatever and so
um there were a few moments where we had
to go okay let's acknowledge this we
know this is kind of a small problem but
this can get worse because we saw this
other thing that we thought ah it's just
a small little problem like let's just
ignore it and then it kind of got worse
or whatever
um so those that was kind of a big thing
for us to be like let's pause let's make
sure to resolve any sort of conflict
let's be sure to clear up any sort of
confusion even if it's just small issues
here and there
um and that was that was something that
was really vital and helped us out a lot
and made things much smoother as we went
through the rest of production
so basically there were no small
problems like you looked at everything
as how could this
bite Us in the back at some point yeah
yeah definitely because I think another
thing too was like
moods of cast and crew members and some
of us didn't realize I mean myself
included but me and a couple of the
other people on set sometimes we'd get
in a bad mood or or we'd yeah get
irritable and then we'd see oh it's
actually affecting everyone else and
then now these actors are going into a
scene and they've just been around some
arguing or some negative environment or
some complaining and now the scene's not
going to play out as good because their
mindset is a little bit distracted or a
little more negative than it should be
you know so those were things that we
had to
rewind and take account of and and be
like okay we need to we need to realize
whatever is happening on set and
whatever the the emotions are on set we
need to make sure that this is a healthy
and a good environment you know because
that's going to translate onto screen
that's a great Point actors are like
sponges they pick up in there everything
in their environment and so so would you
then take things maybe away from them
sometimes that might be hard if you need
to address something in the moment how
would you handle that so that if there
was something that needed a dressing you
could do it where
it wouldn't spread to the rest of the
room I mean there was like moments where
I'd have to
um take people aside you know whether
it's like a disagreement or whether
there was like I said a confusion you
know like maybe me and Connor the DP if
we weren't seeing eye to eye on the shot
he thinks it should be this way I think
it should be this way it's like okay
well let's not have this conversation in
front of everyone else let's go over
here and talk about it and so that
worked really well and then same with
the actors if it's like okay I like the
way the scene is going like this one you
know this actress is doing great and
then he's not doing so good or whatever
then you'd be like okay let me pull him
aside and talk to him about it and try
to adjust or vice versa whatever it was
um you know sometimes you need to talk
to two people you know sometimes you
need to talk to just one but don't have
sensitive conversations or conversations
that not everyone needs to hear don't
have that in front of everyone there's
something to be said about like having
private conversations privately